One of my favorite stories I read about you
and Jesse Tyler Ferguson was visiting a frat house
in your hometown.
Please tell me about it.
Oh my gosh, yes.
So we went back to my Alma mater, Kansas State University,
and Jesse was like, "Where did you live when you were here?"
I said, "Well, I lived in a fraternity house."
He's like, "Let's go."
And this was like at 12...
After the bars were closing.
So we just roll over and we go to my old room,
knock on the door, nobody answers,
and check the door and go in.
And there is a lovely young couple up in a bed,
like pull the blankets back.
And I'm like "Hi."
And this is like at the height of "Modern Family."
So they're like what the bleep is going...
Mitch and Cam are standing in their room.
They're post coitus.
Oh they're post...
Post coitus.
Okay, I see.
They're in the after glow and bliss.
Yes.
And then there you are here.
Here we are!
Hi!
Were you like, I used to live here.
Yeah!
I used to do this here.
I love it.
I love it so much.
But okay, there was also a picture of you
and one of the goddesses of all times.
Oh yes.
Hey Rhi Rhi.
So like from a dorm room bedroom to this moment.
Oh, man.
This was at the women in film party at the Chateau one year.
Right.
And I'm there with lots of my friends
and doing the Hollywood thing, hanging out, right.
And I had seen Rihanna across the room
but I'm not the person to be able to go over
and say anything.
Well, at one point I look over
and she's just going like this to me.
So I walk over and her group was like,
"Rihanna watches the show, we love it so much."
And she's like asked for a picture.
I'm like, "Yes, I wanted a picture,
but I just didn't have the courage
to come over and ask for one."
That's not the best part.
What's the best part?
The best part is Jesse, my, you know, co-star,
and his husband were at the party that night
and they wanted to get a picture,
but Jesse did the same thing I did,
it's like, I'm not going over to Rihanna
and bothering her for a picture.
I'm not doing it.
So I go to work the next morning.
Jesse's like, "Eric!"
He's like, "You got me in so much trouble last night."
I'm like, "What happened?"
He's like, "The picture of you and Rihanna."
I'm like, "She asked me, I didn't do it.
It's not my fault."
You're like, "It's Rihanna."
Yeah, and why would I...
Yeah.
So anyway, that's my Rihanna story.
I love all of this.
And I also love that you are totally open and honest,
that it wasn't all bells and whistles and easy street.
You were working your butt off.
You were Mr. Commercials.
You were doing a ton of commercials.
I have a clip-
Oh boy.
Of a commercial of you right now.
Look, there you are.
Oh my gosh.
(audience applause)
How do I look like a 55 year old insurance agent,
25 years ago?
I don't know.
That's so weird.
It's totally the outfit by the way.
They literally like...
It's like almost like a cliche, they're like office guy.
(upbeat music)